[Music]
I know you guys are big-time and there's
a lot of people gonna watch this video
so if for the people that watch this
video if you leave with one thing out of
this video even though there's much more
important things being said about life
and happiness and making money about
just playing the game perfectly in my
opinion this is what I want you to leave
with when you go into a wine shop not
only if you remember what you like or
don't or know what you like or don't no
matter what it is or you have no idea
just like the question was asked you
have to try a wine from a varietal
you've never had before please don't buy
another Pinot Grigio another's in
another Pinot Noir
a different kind of Chardonnay no tan at
she known you know Rueda albariño you
know these are the things I want you to
look for you've got to try a wine from
kejoro you know from Bon dole from you
know a torrontés from Argentina so the
answer is this I can tell you right now
you are a wine expert if you spend two
years and in that window you never order
the same kind of wine and if you do that
and then you once you hit all the wines
you can kind of find Gruner Veltliner
Rieslings from germany reasonings from
washington state you know different
places making different grapes you're
gonna be shocked of what you know and
how much you understand your palate
because everybody who's watching this
right now here's what you're really
doing
you're only drinking coke and sprite
every meal and you have no idea of root
beer Hawaiian Punch grape soda
black cherry you have no clue tomato
juice pomegranate juice you have no idea
if you like those because you're
sticking to Pinot Grigio and Pinot Noir
please for me try something new
there's two countries right now that I
think you can be very safe in finding
some really neat stuff one is South
Africa if you order a Chenin Blanc or
find a Chenin Blanc very crisp very
clean very aromatic great with shellfish
and light salads you can get them from
eight to twelve bucks all day long and
in red hands-down the dominant country
and value in my opinion is Portugal
you know Portugal is just ripping I
think the quality out of Portugal for
seven to twelve dollars is staggering I
actually want to do a 2020 investigation
and how much these people are getting
paid over there because I do can't
figure out the math of how the lines can
be so good and they can deliver them for
seven bucks so from the dotto the Dow
Alentejo these are places that really
make some great great Portuguese wines
what your palate likes so the makers for
sure the pedigree is important right
you know this builder is good you know
the chef's good you know this car maker
is good you've got a reference point to
knowing if the wines going to be good
but this is farming I don't care if
you're the best winemaker of all time if
it rains every day you're finished so
that's also very very important what I
think is most important when you first
start learning is understanding the
grape varietals understanding the
difference between Chenin Blanc and
Sauvignon Blanc and Riesling and Pinot
Noir and Pinot Gris and there's a lot
there that will really be the foundation
of what you like
the real move like the date move is to
like Google asked you know like a select
Eric grape varietals right and just like
ask for like you know do you need late
harvest Grenache from the ban you'll you
know totally like throw off the Somme
with the mad skills but you've got like
only one move if you want to be a little
bit more authentic which I highly
recommend I think it's imperative to
name off three wines that you've had in
the past that you've liked and that's
the sommelier to go in a different
direction with varietal or from a
different country you know me and to
expand your palate I think you know
there's a romance with you know being on
a date of saying you know to your date
you know let's explore some new stuff
together kind of thing I like cabs but
what else would I like
well you might like to Matt because
there's big tannins a big fruit you know
and so that would always be something
that would be my go-to move
you know I think if we're living the
Google era right I mean I feel like you
learn so much more by reading good blogs
like the nog raphy or fermentation dr.
vino there's there's just too many good
resources from the blogosphere and from
forums and you know what I love about
corked is not only can you review the
wines but then people can comment on
those reviews so like creating threaded
conversations around wines I think is
very cool and so I'm excited about the
fact that I don't think people have to
spend $150 for a class or you know
necessarily buy a book now both are so
worthwhile classes there's that
engagement interaction books it's kind
of there with you can you know you know
I still think there's nice romance about
a book though I'm thrilled for Kindle or
ereader or whatever you know however you
why I Pro knock yourself out it's all
about the content but I think there's so
much free content out there that I don't
necessarily need to sit here and
recommend a source that's going to hit
somebody in the wallet save those 20
bones to buy a good bottle wine
yeah we were talking outside and you
know I was saying you'd be shocked what
happens between 15 and 25 the wine world
right now 25 to 40 bones you can drink
world class stuff that you know you
start getting into the shot at the pop
world pre or at world you start getting
into wine set you can't necessarily get
to under 15 and they're really
sensational really I feel like the
quality of a wine given the depressed
market and given the advances in farming
a $30 wine today probably tasted as good
as most sixty to eighty dollar wines a
decade ago that's powerful I mean you
know it's powerful it's a very good
direction for the wine drinker I think
it's very obvious and so if I could say
anything if you're into wine you know
you start looking seriously at 25 to 40
bones you can get some crazy stuff
no you're going to overpay
that's all I got nothing there I mean
why do the month clubs are fine listen I
created one for Gary Vaynerchuk and Wine
Library TV because I wanted to create
one that was legit
I mean people getting ripped off they're
paying full value for fancy packaging in
the letter that says thank you you know
so you know no
I think that the best way to do that is
to find sources that you respect and
trust whether that's one number TV or
another blogger or local wine merchants
you know that that's the only way he's
going to keep you is by giving you great
service saying don't buy that try this
but I really do think we're going to see
an explosion and things like worked I
mean that's why I'm so bullish on it and
launching it now I think Yelp has
provided a platform that people
understand that community driven scoring
has value and I think that's going to
come to wine in a big way
[Music]